I cannot believe this but the media is
slightly less hated this year then they
were last year that's right forty-four
percent of respondents in a new gallup
poll say that they have a great deal or
a fair amount of trust and confidence in
mass media that's actually identical to
2011 but it's up slightly four points
from forty percent in 2012 I'm sort of
shocked by this because the more we have
social media the more we see all the
constant errors every time something's
breaking on CNN they make ten different
errors and they retract it and people
take away tweets and now you know I mean
every time something happens there's a
well that source or we got that one
wrong Fox does it all the time too let's
take a look at the graph here so you can
see it's uh it's peaking up justice a
little on its way up at the end there
just a tiny bit and we're only talking
about four points but that is something
you think it may be would be dumping 20
points and the biggest jump
interestingly is in Republicans and
independents that are trusting the media
yes I don't understand it's like the
media the media is reporting that we're
more trusted says the media you know
it's like it's like me being like
according to whitney mixter Whitney is
thinner and smarter than last year says
I you know it's like it's like I don't
understand what who's where is this
coming from that was enough time for you
to touch your own reporting live yes
it's true I am smarter than last year um
no but and also where is anybody also
reporting on whether or not they trust
polls no great because they're so who
gets you know I got a call for the first
time in my life this week I got a call
from Quinnipiac that's a college in
Connecticut that does they do the big
ones all right you're from Connecticut
right yeah have you ever been to the
polling station over a Quinnipiac yes
absolutely I spent my summers there well
I got a call from them this week and
they said we wanted to know you know if
you'd be involved in this poll and I was
excited because i was like i never got
one of these clothes no he was something
well i don't know what it was because i
said well how long is it gonna take and
they said about 12 minutes
and I was like I don't know that but
even think about that who has time for a
12-minute poll so the people you're
getting in the polls already are a map
of people that I guess just have a lot
of time on their hands that means people
call them they're like you have told me
oh yeah I got time do you trust the
media sure the way I was looking for
someone oh yeah that wasn't even yeah
yeah yeah how we doing yeah so forty-six
percent of the people polled in this
gallup poll say the media is too liberal
thirteen percent say it's too
conservative and 37 per se présente it's
just about right like porridge does that
I mean to any of those numbers what are
they gonna say like they're gonna be
like no I don't trust them they're shady
you know that it at low you always have
your favorite sources like you love
Anderson Cooper so you always have your
do you have somebody that you feel like
when you're watching them is a little
more is like CNN is in the middle cuz I
I am myself when I'm independent like I
have to hear you know what the topic is
sometimes I'm conservative own thing
sometimes I'm liberal on things it
depends on what it is although i do
shine more towards liberal but um yeah I
think but you have a person I like an
actual person that you go at that guy
seems Samantha shocker yes yes yes on
HLN she's amazing yes yes dr. drew yes
um but I don't have I don't I don't
follow a specific person per se I'd like
to just kind of and that goes to how I
am in politics I'd kind of like to see I
like to sprinkle it all here at all you
know judge also to speak but I'm much
more interested in you know what's being
said on the talk about about my favorite
celebs I gotta be honest I'm a total
gossip like love that stuff well that's
why you get a shout-out to hard yes so
ever Sam rough it's still rough I got it
I got to hear something else yeah yeah
um but no yeah like you said like it's
according to who this is happening like
what kind of agenda is gonna be like I
don't trust your your you trust your
atoms are you just that you don't trust
I question you yeah
like I don't even trust that yeah so I
mean whatever it's one of those silly
things that I think is it's funny but I
don't really pay much attention to and I
don't you know yeah but they should
trust the media blindly anyway and
that's why what we do here at the Young
Turks there's no corporate influence and
even though I do have something in my
ear it's just so I can hear the audio of
videos I don't have someone barking
instructions at me at least right this
second I assure you that I don't but
actually if I was going to say one or
two people that I do sort of think are a
little more honest in media I think Jake
Tapper on CNN is pretty decent he always
looks depressed which i think is a sign
of someone trying to tell the truth he
has like his fate he's very sort of got
these sort of lines in his face that
imply like I know I'm sort of stuck in
this thing and I like Erin Burnett